So why is it that we are susceptible to cancer?
Okay.
The evolution of maintenance mechanisms,
which is associated with the evolution of aging has been such that maintenances
neglected for good reasons.
Let me,
collective maintenance allows better reproduction.
We have stem cells and we need them for repair,
but they are pre adapted for metro stations.
There really aren't genes for cancer.
Most of the genes that are involved in cancer actually are doing something else
early in development.
The possibility for somatic mutation is simply enormous.
The numbers are overwhelming.
So what are the causes of aging?
We have covered some of these in previous lectures,
but it's a good idea here to have a recap because this is the context in which
our vulnerability for cancer arises.
Aging is a byproduct of selection for reproductive performance.
That's the essential idea
in this process.
Maintenance is neglected in order to improve reproduction.
Aging arises through the evolutionary accumulation of many genes that have
positive effects on fitness early in life and negative effects on fitness late
in life.
So there are benefits outweigh their costs.
From the point of view of evolution,
which is not the point of view of a patient with cancer.
First we reduced mortality that is caused by infectious disease.
We did it with hygiene,
vaccines and antibiotics,
mostly in the 20th century.
Then cardiovascular disease emerged as a major killer.
Then we improve the prevention and treatment of cardiovascular disease,
but we started dying more frequently of cancer and Alzheimer's.
There isn't really any end of that insight.
Now the second,
uh,
idea in why we are vulnerable to cancer is the multicellular covenant.
So this picture is designed to elicit the notion of multicellularity.
This is a multicellular Alga and the bright green dots are the reproductive
cells.
The smaller,
darker green dots are the somatic cells that are engaged in photosynthesis,
and they gather the energy and give it to the reproductive cells,
which get the genes into the next generation.
So somatic cells stop reproducing.
Germ cells propagate the genes,
stem cells repair tissue cancer breaks this covenant.
Most of the cancers originate in stem cells.
So stem cells arose with multicellularity or great innovation.
There are about a billion years old.
They appear to divide slowly and they retain the potential to differentiate.
Slow Division would reduce cancer frequency potential to differentiate and to
move pre adapts them to a cancerous lifestyle.
Okay.
They are positioned all over the body to replace cells that we're out in our
discarded,
particularly in bone marrow,
in lungs,
intestine,
in skin,
and the epithelium there.
Capacity for self renewal and their potential to differentiate pre adapt them to
a cancerous lifestyle.
No.
How
are somatic cells normally kept under control?
Well,
early in development,
the germ cell germline is physically isolated,
at least in organisms like us,
that prevents invasion from the Soma.
So that keeps somatic cells from defecting from the Covenant and going back and
getting their genes into the next generation.
Tumor suppressor genes control differentiation and deal with them.
So if a sales starts to proliferate when it should not,
it receives a signal to commit suicide.
A pop ptosis.
If DNA is damaged and attempt is made to repair it,
but if the damage cannot be repaired,
then the cell receives a signal to kill itself.
Both of these responses are controlled by the tumor suppressor gene p 53 in
cancer biology,
you hear a lot about p 53 one Crucell mutation on the weed of cancer is the one
that disables the response to a signal to commit suicide.
So here is a figure of a t cell in orange volunteer in a pop toci cells.
So that t-cell has received a signal that the DNA in this,
a pop toasting cell is defective and cannot be repaired and it's giving it a
signal to commit suicide.
Cancer ignores that signal.
So where do the somatic mutations come from?
Well,
some of it's bad luck for mistakes.
During the duplication of the genome and cell division.
Every time a cell divides about 3 billion nucleotides have to be copied and no
copying processes.
Perfect evolution has also adjusted the mutation rate longterm to be low but non
zero.
It's about 10 to the minus ninth per nucleotide per cell division about one in a
billion probability that a single nucleotide at a specific site will mutate in a
soul division.
Somatic mutations can be increased by exposure to environmental mutagens like
ultraviolet light or tobacco smoke.
There were free that are
released during inflammation,
protons,
so inflammation can actually cause somatic mutation.
In most cases.
Chronic exposure is much worse than acute exposure.
So something like a longterm helicobacter pylori infection in the gut in the
stomach,
which is making stomach ulcers is going to provide,
provide chronic exposure,
a lot of inflammation,
and that can then lead to somatic mutation causing gastric cancer.
Inactivation of a DNA repair gene like p 53 greatly increases the mutation rate.
Now are there really genes that are for cancer?
Well,
there aren't really any genes that are designed to produce cancer.
There are genes mutations in which can lead to cancer.
Most genes for cancer actually functioned in early embryogenesis.
They mediate cell migration,
cell adhesion,
induction,
clonal proliferation,
other normal functions.
They are healthy genes that are turned off during terminal differentiation of
tissue.
It is carcinogenic mutations that disturb the epigenetic controls on these jeans
that release normal cell functions at developmentally inappropriate points.
So these genes are examples of antagonistic fly tropey if natural selection
where to protect us from cancer by eliminating these genes,
which all have useful functions in early embryogenesis than early development
would fail.
Instead selection has reinforced controls and provided mechanisms to detect and
correct or eliminate cells that have precancerous mutation.
Yes,
so heritable dis a predisposition to cancer often involves a heritable
deficiency in these control and surveillance mechanisms.
We should also recognize that not all somatic mutations are equally dangerous.
About 1% of the genes in the genome.
That's about 350 are involved in producing cancer in oncogenesis.
It is usually mutations in stem cells,
not in differentiated tissue that produce cancer
mutations that occur early in development or the most important because they
present have the chance to produce a lineage of many cells within which other
mutations can then accumulate
each cell lineage in the body then develops a unique history with more than 10
to the 16th cells per individual per lifetime.
The cell lineage history within each of us is larger than the history of all of
the individual humans who have ever lived.
So we have to recognize that the number of cell division events going on and
producing an individual human is enormous and carries with it enormous
opportunity for somatic mutation.
Yeah,
that's important because cancer is a numbers game.
Cancer's result when a series of somatic mutations accumulate and there are a
lot of somatic mutations during development.
The single celled Zygote expands to about 10 to the 13th the 10 to the 14th
cells.
That requires about the same total number of cell divisions.
The somatic mutation rate per gene per cell division is about 10 to the minus
seventh or 10 to the minus sixth and if we put those numbers together,
the number of total somatic mutation events per gene per gene per individual is
about 10 to the six to 10 to the eighth
every gene in the genome you Tate's many times in the Soma of every individual.
That's a rather frightening conclusion,
but it comes inevitably from some pretty simple arithmetic.
So why are some tissues more susceptible to cancer than to others?
Yeah,
the epithelium and lungs and skin is more exposed to carcinogens in the
environment than our other tissues in general.
Cancer is lot more likely in mitotically active tissues for each round of
mytosis is an opportunity for mutation.
So we see more cancers in the hematopoietic cells,
the Leukemias and Lymphomas,
which are coming from lineages of immune cells than we do in red blood cell
cancers.
We see endometrial cancer but not Fallopian tube cancer because the endometrium
is dividing with each menstrual cycle.
We see cancer's a secretory tissues in gut,
breast,
cervix,
prostate and so forth,
but not in the smooth muscle of the gut or in the smooth muscle of the
reproductive system.
Children are much more susceptible to brain and bone cancers than adults because
those tissues are growing rapidly in shoulder with many cell divisions.
But they are not divided.
They are not growing actively in adults,
which do not have very many cells that are dividing in their brain and in their
bone.
Yeah.
Oh.
When cancers do appear in non mitotically active tissues,
they are likely to be secondary sites resulting from metastasis from primary
tumor.
So to summarize,
we age is a byproduct of selection for reproduction and that means that
maintenance has been neglected in order organisms for good reasons to support
earlier in life,
better reproductive performance.
Okay,
we need stem cells to maintain our tissues,
but mutations in stem cells can add two characteristics that predisposed stem
cells to become cancerous.
So if a stem cell turns on some of its capacities at inappropriate times and
places,
it can easily become cancerous.
Okay?
We do need a modest mutation rate to maintain evolution.
And the opportunities then for somatic mutation are immense.
So even though the mutation rate has been adjusted down to 10 to the minus ninth
per nucleotide per cell division,
which is the low rate needed by evolution,
the number of cell divisions in somatic development is so great that there are
millions of somatic mutations.
Okay?
We need cell functions early in development that would be cancerous later in
development if not properly controlled.
And so if there are mutations to the control systems,
cancer can develop,
okay?
Humans are especially vulnerable because we have a long post reproductive
period.
And because we are exposed to novel risk factors and we have an unusual
sexuality.
Yeah.
The bottom line is that we trade vulnerability to cancer for valuable benefits,
reproduction,
tissue maintenance,
evolve ability development and sexuality.